dude are you seeing this the whole Los
Angeles is on fire
Shh
good Matthew Bradley Oh Lord here thanks
riff thanks with house dude crazy fire
yeah I know too so couldn't be here
she's worked late okay that's cool this
promise you did all this for you other
balloons and stuff so you didn't you
didn't do it no bond boy I gotta snap
out of course oh yeah Sue's dish big
house cool cool how are the shows I'm
into haven't seen use good man yeah
everything's going wrong I just can't
believe you're I know man you leaving us
now I mean no don't don't I don't want
to call you know I I don't want this to
be about yeah I'm just wanting to be a
fun time yeah I hate to have a party in
man but I do I've got a buddy who's
living up the street I've got help
evacuate so you don't mind is throwing
your own I'll be back but I gotta go
help him move so I wouldn't worry about
it but just just so i know what i mean
if we need to get evacuated do they
knock on my door it's not about Lena
yeah but it sure as hell looks like
moving that fast I know it does doesn't
it oh gosh I wouldn't worry about all
right oh dude he never gets my ran into
today boom Milton yeah just booked this
huge role on his television so I think
he's like the main character or
something I kid I couldn't believe it so
I was like yeah dude you gotta come over
we gotta shoot the make you know
catch up any can you don't say goodbye
yeah i mean that's fine i probably
wouldn't invite invited him but I mean
you know the more tired well I got
a bowl dude obviously the fires going
yeah
you're fleep fleep what's up
no listen man
ok man
teacher I need to me
Joshua
yeah what's up i doing that were you in
goes without saying all right
congratulations I'll talk to you soon
hello
oh man
ah
for volunteer I just I just got here so
glad to see you guys
yes hey how a smarty man so happy to see
you absolutely now we've been good good
i wilt I feel better click on live with
a break we'll see them oh man I got this
how are you I'm good you good you look
good thanks all right
hi Jordan hey people the world is
completely on fire but you know we're
here and range along sounds like a 40
west yeah it's like stairs how's it
going how's it going your video action
was a shadow map thankfully be going
right what's up man how's it going oh
yeah they are oh sorry I'm think about
yeah me and then he got all her plans
way
sorry Anna take care o senator and lap
she questions sunrise
babe
mush yeah she knows yes right sometimes
gives me right all right copy what you
know want to like them in me
Wow hey goose together starts cutting my
hair usually takes mat bring your ass
right here put your seat right here is
my moment now set your ass down
man fires blazing I'm here now this
guy's taking off the going to DC you
want best boy but I can't understand you
came out here you invited me to a party
I here in this weather blazing fire
trucks outside man let
me ask you a question you dressed up
with event how old's that sue I
seriously anywhere that before my bday
recital y'all know this guy should stay
with me it's like a twice three times I
thought you'd be north in the morning
every time I wake up in the one you're
here like 80s porn is like what the
is that small and you get here how cuz
he purrs when you know it blows his load
come on my journey on that one you're
funny guy I seriously but honestly met
all of us we ought to tell you right now
we love you you gotta go breaking my
heart because
you're the one that stood up for me
when I was down you talked my
ear off late at night it's gonna be hard
without you man
I wish you don't go man please don't go
don't go give me a hug man he got me her
really not gonna toss you see thanks a
lot
indeed yeah I was cool that you invited
me to this sucks that your sucks that
you're leavin man no you know I wish you
much success and I just wanted to say
you know like Casey Kasem says just keep
your feet on the ground and reach for
the sky they say you don't have
something good to say if I shouldn't say
anything but I'm gonna say something
anyway
you are a quitter wherever you go I just
hope there aren't too many mirrors cuz I
don't think you don't look at yourself
and when you wake up you know every day
from now on I hope the first thing you
think is if I'd help on for one more day
that would have been the day I don't
wish you well when I edit the film
you're in I pretended someone else I
don't know I don't know how many also
say to you
you